dann hat mich gar nicht nach einer
fahndung auf freien fuß wieder gelassen
man hat mich davor geführt wie der
grösste schwerverbrecher mit
handschellen fußfessel ja und dann
kommen sie dann in seine zelle reihen
bei 40 grad sicherheitsverwahrung also
richtig krass ohne arbeit 23 stunden
lang türe zu eingeschlossen dann muss
man nie wie spät es war
man sieht doch viel und was man
eigentlich denkt das gibt es nur im
fernsehen oder im film aber das passiert
wirklich in der jva
[Musik]
ja das gefühl ist gar nicht zu
beschreiben du kannst die tür wieder
selber auf machen so man lernt einfach
andere dinge wieder schützen
[Musik]
es tut mir sehr leid das haben wir echt
viele leute geholfen die ich dann extrem
in deutsch gesagt und die presse
getreten habe
über jahre habe ich mal gesehen die
anderen sind schuld nein die anderen
licht rückt ich hab das alleine verbockt